der bundesvion Song Contest steht wieder
vor der Tür kurz buvisoku und seit wir
es letztes Jahr gemacht haben ist es
quasi Tradition die Teilnehmer stellen
sich auch bei uns vor den Anfang macht
Andreas borani aus Bayern und für ihn
gibt es ein Youtube Parten white Titi
unterstützen ihn sie stammen ja aus
hilpolstein und das was ich auch sage
was white Titi gleich sagen wird wenn
ihr Andreas borani gut findet und wollt
dass er den buisoko gewinnt dann diesem
Video thumbs ab geben favorisieren und
so weiter damit die Welt davon erfährt
dass es ihn gibt und dass SE Song
Eisberg nicht von schlechten Eltern
ist jo jetzt Andreas Bani bei mir der
Teilnehmer beim bundeswischen Song
Contest für Bayern wie kommt man zu der
Ehre ja ich habe mich einfach beworben
das so dass man sich da bewirbt und und
dann eine Zusage bekommen und läuft das
über die PL also weil du bist ja ganz
neu und wie kommt dann dass S sag Boran
ja noch nie gehört ja ja es lief
tatsächlich über die Plattenfirma auch
ich glaube also ist bei jeder Band so
dass du dass dann die plattenf sagt ja
hast du Bock irgendwie mitzumachen und
man sich dann einfach bewirbt ein Song
dahinschickt und dann wählt da die
Redaktion und mit Stefan Rab zusammen
die wählen dann einfach aus und warum
haben sie dich ausgewählt war du der
Einzige aus weß ich war nicht dabei ich
war nicht dabei bei dem Meeting aber ich
schätze weil es irgendwie gepasst hat
weil es musikalisch gepasst hat ist ja
auch so dass es
eine Unterhaltungssendung ja auch ist
geht um Musik ist eine Musiksendung und
ja dass man auch einfach ein
unterschiedliche Künstler einfach da hat
ne und das unterschiedliche Musik ist
hat gut gepasst einfach okay und bei dir
passt ja vor allen Dingen du kommst
wirklich aus Bayern weil manchmal hat
man so Truppen und dann kommt eben der
Bassist kommt aus Saland oder keine
Ahnung schwiig mE bei mir ist relativ
einfach weil ich halt Solokünstler bin
aber hast du recht wenn es dann vier
fünf Leute sind und man ist nicht
wirklich von der peke auf irgendwie
zusammen aufgewachsen und dann kommt der
eine halt aus Hamburg Bremen und der
andere aus Bayern dann wird's natürlich
schwierig da muss man sich ja fast
entscheiden ne für welches Bundesland
andtritt okay ja und aufgeregt ja total
aufgeregt auf der einen Seite klar L
fiber habe ich sowieso immer das kommt
dann kurz vorher aber auch ich ich will
es ja gewinnen ja ja ja ich will ja ich
geh rein bin so ein Typ der auch sagt
wenn es irgendwie um zocken geht und um
um spielen so Wettbewerb dann habe ich
auch den Anspruch ich will auch gewinnen
klar ist natürlich auch da dabei sein
alles sind tolle Künstler und B dabei
aber ich will das Ding nach Bayern holen
gut okay apropos genau Bayern hat ja
noch nie gewonnen ne ja t ist so es wä
mal an der Zeit jetzt auch für Bayern
okay okay apropos tolle Konkurrenz hast
du die mal ang wie schätzt du deine
Chancen ein ich habe noch nicht alle
Songs gehört muss ich sagen aber die
Bands hat sich auch mal geguckt wer wer
alles da ist und sind sind wirklich gute
Leute dabei muss sagen ist geht eh
gerade viel mit mit deutscher Musik auch
deutsche Popmusik Jupiter Jones dai
Frieder Gold sind dabei axel Bosse ist
auch dai mit dem habe ich ja auch eine
Nummer für meine Platte geschrieben
zusammen es wird wird eine spannende
Show auf jeden Fall wie ist es
eigentlich so wenn man gegeneinander
anditt redet man d nicht mehr
miteinander vorher doch doch schon ist
ja nicht so dass man doch doch
das wä gut ja so so ein kleinen Krieg
nee also es ist schon so dass man auch
noch miteinander redet ja weil es ist ja
wie gesagt am Ende steht da der
Spaßfaktor da im im Mittelpunkt das ja
mehr so mitm augenzwinel sagt ich will
da gewinnen und so dann den ansprun hat
aber ich denke jeder dritt auch so ein
bisschen an und rechnet sich Chancen aus
irgendwie eine gute Platzierung zu
kriegen super dann wünsche ich dir wie
ich allen aber wünschen werde viel
Erfolg ja vielen Dank aber fast
vergessen es gibt natürlich jetzt dein
Youtube Parten der dir auch noch mal die
Daumen drückt der partte ja vielen Dank
und an alle fleißig für Bayern wen wir
sind white ti und unterstütz natürlich
Bayern genau Andreas Bani ist dafür der
Kandidat bundesvion Song Contest 2011
Jungs gibt's noch irgendwas zu sagen
voten auf Youtube hier Daumen nach oben
wenn ihr Andreas burani unterstützt oder
schaltet ein Pro 7 und da anrufen und
wir sagen
Bayern ja super vielen Dank die
Unterstützung kann ich gebrauchen ja
fleißig verbeiwen bis
dann